[Música]
eu vi uma tarde quando já me apresentar
o meu nome é catarina ferreira em 1910 e
isto é um caminho assim no instituto
politécnico de viseu no curso de
tecnologia design e multimédia
eu vou tentar ver se livre exatamento
companhia em casa deverão perder mas
provavelmente vai acontecer porque eu
estou extremamente nervosa mas vamos
continuar
quando eu sou qualquer o tema que tinha
que falar
fiquei um caso cada rosa mais uma vez
porque nessa nova i mo futuro ainda não
aconteceram muitas coisas na minha vida
mas no entanto acho que já tem algumas
coisas que eu posso partilhar e e que
acha que são importantes e espero que os
inspire de alguma maneira a eu gosto
muito de planejar e pensar no meu futuro
é tenha escaninhos e faz listas tudo que
eu tenho que fazer a minha é de 70 é
raro as coisas acontecerem como o
planeio mas eu continuo apanhado é mesmo
e aos 15 anos sem planear muito vai e é
claro que eu quis tirar um curso numa
vinha na minha escola
então eu falei com os meus pais e minha
decisão eu quero seguir artes visuais
mas não aqui em vivire voltar para casa
para estar aqui em viseu era complicado
para mim porque aqui em nome dos
transportes
e então eu ser uma opção de estudar pra
margem isso e ver com a minha tia e eu
quem diziam anos zahara caiu a viajar
daqui então lá fui eu é a longo prazo
visivelmente não correu muito bem e mais
uma vez eu consegui me queixar que ela
que já fazia carlo 15 anos nem entrou
com uma queixa não é agora o que falta
já não é o sítio natura river porque
estava a poucos minutos da equipe da
capital com tinha muito mais
oportunidades têm acesso é muito mais
coisas há muito mais movimento de
pessoas e portanto as circunstâncias
estavam lá mas eu não estava fazendo
nada por mim na minha
é continuar a fazer o mesmo que fazia cá
e igual então é você ver que realmente
se calhar o problema era para viver com
a minha tia e falei com os meus pais a
gente não está a resultar é não tomar
banho etc
para ele o terceiro ano do secundário é
eles alugaram um quarto
eu fui pra casa com mais três rapazes
ela tudo correr bem é eu continuar ou
não fazer nada por mim na mesma continua
a queixar-se sempre as lamentações
constantes na minha cabeça eu até não
era muito chato infelizmente não falar
muito com as minhas amigas sobre isso
coitadas mexe eu sempre li e continuava
sem fazer nada da vida deixei de um
tempo atrás ainda no também e pronto
os meus pais também não gostava muito
daquela brincadeira né é então eu disse
uma vez que ele é melhor eu tirar um gap
e no final do secundário e não já podem
retirar porque eu lá vou continuar a
fazer o mesmo
até acho que é uma boa idéia porque foi
durante este ep que eu comecei a
trabalhar numa pastelaria é e consegue
tirar a carta e estava a tentar também
terminou de um triângulo pronto tanto o
trabalho natal estaria tudo o que ouve e
mais tudo ouvir o que eu ouvia mais
grande maioria eram implementações
queixas dos clientes entra num novo
patrão obter algumas é sempre queixas
constantes e toda olha as minhas amigas
também que a chance da vida delas e o
caixão da minha vida e isso é uma
constante lamentação e pronto eu tinha
muito mais tempo para pensar grande
equipe que não tinha uma trabalhadora
sol durante o dia e à noite ia para casa
ele tava pra não tinha muito o que
pensar então lamentável ainda mais e foi
que eu consegui fletir de pensar olha de
facto as circunstâncias talvez não seja
o problema é dúvida porque já tiveste é
viver no melhor sítio para fazer alguma
coisa e não fizesse nada para agravar o
problema e tatá e não saber falar muito
bem e de fato não sei só a ter um crime
mais atenção am nos meus pensamentos
deixar de lamentar tantas vezes
comigo própria e cada vez que tinha uma
festa que já estava extinto cuiabá não
sei o que pensar de treino pensar em
outra coisa e e perigos que isso
especialmente essa mudança de pensamento
criativo aconteceu no início do ano
passado sofre há pouco tempo e desde aí
até agora é a minha vida mudou
não foi informada a fama dessa super
radical mesmo muito é pra melhor e eu
sinto muito melhor e acho que isso é que
é importante porque como já estava ali
ele que é o caso é nós fazemos nosso
futuro agora eu acho que nós tivemos
contentes agora minimamente com aquilo
que temos e e já nos minimamente prática
aquilo que já temos conseguimos pensar
no futuro melhor para nós e atingir um
futuro melhor para nós e tudo era
prender um triplo é então o brasil
também não quer que é e está a terminar
aí é estavam querendo nervosa para que
chegasse à altura de meter candidataram
a universidade porque apesar de que o
trabalho que o pessoal fazendo a
pastelaria ser muito cansativo é de 60
não é não dar tanto instantes 3 com uma
escola porque aquela opção da das notas
das 67 61 e pronto é como eu não
terminei de um quisto fazer de cadeiras
isoladas é e está a correr muito melhor
e eu saí tenha certeza acredito mesmo
que é isso deve-se a minha mudança no
meu pensamento deixar de me queixar
tanto porque eu eu sinto que toda a
gente se queixa é imenso e que é sempre
um entrave nas nossas vidas e nós é que
temos de executar o nosso futuro estando
constantemente com este pensamento
sempre a queixar mas que as coisas não
correm bem e não correm bem e muitas
vezes nós é que não fizemos nada por
isso porque temos medo medo de falhar e
sentra e fazemos essas queixas como
desculpas para que eles voltarem a
acontecer ele não acontecer porque nós
mantemos focados naquilo que ainda não
temos
em vez de pensar no que podemos fazer
para atingir essas mesmas coisas
no fundo eu acho que esse é o que eu
quero transmitir
mas é que é deixarmos de por tantas
desculpas e e e ter esse pensamento
negativo nos trazem é em nada para o
nosso futuro
ontem quando estava a treinar esta manhã
este curso tudo é tal falar com a minha
pergunta no que caixas estão muito
nervosa e não tem nada para dizer porque
não fiz nada e ela estava errada e eu
concordo que o caso dele é 61 feira um
pensamento mais felizes é muito política
ele sim ela nas ã rã e se não tiver um
short até posso usar o meu pensamento e
até ser mais positiva e acho que vai
correr tudo bem e as coisas não
acontecerem e eu após realmente tem
razão mas eu usei esse conceito sorte
porque eu vejo com uma coisa
extremamente pequenina com todos os
seres humanos aqui em relação ao resto
do universo
não somos nada portanto eu não conseguia
acreditar que aquela pessoa aquela
pessoa tenha mais sorte que eu temos
todos a mesma sorte e é uma questão
unificadora é a nossa maneira de pensar
para que as coisas aconteçam e eu
acredito vivamente nisso que primeiro as
coisas acontecem aqui no nosso
pensamento e depois as circunstâncias é
elas aparecem quando menos esperamos
e tudo se alinha preto resultar é tal
começar a acontecer comigo depois de ter
feito esta pequena mudança na minha
maneira de pensar
agora os meus tudo está a correr muito
melhor e eu já no ambiente não é por
causa toda triste
ai meu deus que minha vida é péssima não
tipo olha para as coisas que já tenho e
esse é importante um dia e quando chegar
a altura eu vou atingir os meus
objectivos e aquilo que eu quero para a
minha vida enquanto aquela coisa a seu
tempo
no fundo acho que se eu que eu tenho a
dizer e sim
[Aplausos]
[Música]